the usual swarms of people outside the
Brussels chamber on mini plenary day
where they hear possibly for one special
guest the UN sector generals a message
for Europe came on migration saving
lives should be a cup priority we also
need safe alternatives over to a bit of
disruption and greeted commission first
vice-president timmermans as he laid out
the agenda for the June g7 summit
following the illegal annexation of
Crimea this group meets without Russia
on the table for the summit migration
labor and energy but for members of the
house they questioned whether the g7
were spent force but it got your
sacrifices ether catholique she said a
northerner follow you the g7 needs a
rethink well leadership is shifting to
the BRIC nations much out our duties
quarter ban ki-moon Geraldo domo cruiser
flop shot are you leadership shantou do
bc on SaLuSa giclee moscow circumstance
occurred in european i did he did affair
my embouchure my continued but agreement
finally came on providing free fruit and
veg in schools couldn't okliday keep the
doctor away well any peace will hope it
does